so uh jumping into the movie uh i had so
much fun with this and i think jj some
of these action set pieces are so
good especially let's just go into the
opening one and i'm sorry dave that
you're not in this one but that opening
up
that opening fight sequence with the
grandma is fantastic i really want can
you talk a little bit about filming that
sequence because it's such a great fight
listen to me that's what sold me on the
film when jj showed me the prevails of
that i said yo money
what
is that how is this lady this old lady
doing it and he says their contortions
and this so when we started shooting
that that was the one thing that i
couldn't wait to get into because i
wanted to see how i would look in that
and it turned out amazing
the the trailer i said this all the time
the trailer that we put out over
performed it did 19 million views in
less than 24 hours is because when they
see that shotgun blast and blow that old
granny into the into the kitchen and and
people like what is that and so that
really like speaks to everybody's
interest so i can't wait for people to
tune in and check that out because it
goes hard but when that when you know
when you're shooting a shooting a
grandma into the wall with a shotgun in
the in your first scene that really sets
the tone for the rest of the film and
you know you're in for a good time so
it's true a really good way to come out
of the gate yeah the tone of this movie
is interesting because it's it's funny
it can be serious and it's also like
action-packed can you sort of talk about
the fact that jj does a really good job
balancing it's a tricky thing to do
definitely yeah i mean
my my initial talks with jj he he
basically said hey i got the action
covered you know that's his element
that's where he thrives and he he said
to us he's like i want to lean on you
guys for the comedy i want you to do
your thing and so that basically gave us
permission to just go nuts and just have
fun with each other
and i give i give jamie so much credit
because
he helps set the tone too from from the
get-go where i remember one of the first
scenes we shot was one of the more
serious scenes and so you know i came in
early on and i was trying to do a good
job and i just wanted to you know make
this scene have real weight to it and
jamie came came to me and he was like
you know what yes let's let's give this
weight let's make it have stakes but
also let's let's put a little comedy in
here
and so that was the kind of mindset the
whole way through where he understood
he's like if we can infuse as much
comedy as possible it's just gonna add
that extra layer that makes this movie
that much more fun and i knew i had the
right guy to do it because i literally
told jj i don't want to do the movie
unless dave franco's in the movie i've
been tracking this dude for years man
and i tell people all the time i'm a
comic snob i'm the comic elite people
may make me laugh but i want to know how
he was making me laugh because he was
doing it in such a clever way so by
having him
in that capacity man every time he came
to work he'd have a little bastard you
got something in your bag yellow
something for you
so he killed it right also you know
xavier on the after party i just have to
you know plug that because i love that
you know but anyway
so the other thing is you guys shot this
in 42 days which is not a lot of time
for people that don't realize the making
of movies um did you ever feel like the
pressure when you have such a you know
finite amount of time or was could you
sort of talk about the challenges of
having a tight shooting schedule i mean
jj is a machine he moves so fast he's
been shooting second unit action on the
biggest movies in the world for the last
decade and so he knows exactly what he's
doing that said
we put so much work in before we started
filming in terms of the training so that
when we got on set everyone knew exactly
what they were doing but like i'm
telling you
you know on the normal set if there's
one
stunt
normally everyone kind of like circles
up and it's like all right guys this is
the big stunt day and we're all talking
about it over and over and so much
pressure and jj
we had 50 of those stunts every day and
so he's just he's just you know he's
worked with this stunt team for so long
and they're so dialed in and it's just
like this infectious energy where like
before every take jj literally screams
who wants to try one and then you know
60 of the best stunt people in the world
all in unison go ah
and see we all just feed off that energy
and we just move
and what's crazy is that
allowing us to get in and do those stuff
this guy right here man like he is a
real athlete don't sleep on his stunt
work when he when he you don't want to
give stuff away but when he does his
thing it's crazy which hopefully fingers
crossed people will start watching this
make it make it super hot so we can do
night shift and then we can do that
thing together
but everyone everyone was doing their
own stunts you know snoop came in he was
training with us and like jj shoots in a
way where he's letting things breathe a
little bit and so you can actually see
it's us doing it as opposed to you know
there's some action movies that are cut
up so much that you almost can't even
tell what's going on oh don't get me
started i it makes me crazy as a as a
movie fan when i'm like oh there's 10
cuts in one second oh i got it i
understand what this is you know what i
mean
so one of the cool things is that um
the movie is not john wick with vampires
but there is a john wick element in
terms of like the the vampire union and
the stuff that goes on with all that can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the film and did you borrow any of those
teeth and you know because you know you
needed to keep some yeah
well here's the thing i think that's
what's ingenious about the movie it
makes it blue collar
it's like you know like people were
saying blade i said no you got to see it
it's not blade it's not any of that this
is practical this is a guy harvesting
teeth to go get some money so he could
take care of his kid and it just happens
to be the craziest world that we've
stuck that we stumble that we all
stumble into now i've been in it my
character's been in for a while
but
in
just like sort of like in training day
when denzel takes the money from the
wrong people
and he's about to you know he ends up in
his his demise it's the with me i'm
going against his teeth and i end up
killing that old lady is actually
somebody's daughter
and so then carla uh
who's in incredible in in her part
uh now the stakes become higher it's
like i mess with the i mess with the
wrong vampire in a sense so i think that
having that union
uh sets us up for that if we do want to
do
something more
it you know it's it's a great home base
if that makes it mm-hmm i'm not knowing
i need to stop i'm just gonna say man uh
again thank you for your work and i
really hope it's a huge hit for you guys
and you can you know make another and i
like that title night shift
yeah
third one is graveyard shift